- Le poste frontalier de Palance
de kilomètres seulement
d'Odessa. C'est par la petite
Moldavie que des centaines
de milliers d'Ukrainiensu u u u.
"Il fallait faire quelque chose
pour c c c ces gens qui fuient
une crise à côté de notre pays",
dit Cristina, qui, comme de
à des activités de bénévolat. Mt
pas que des gestes de solidarité
à l'endroit des réfugiéa a a a ,
les Ukrainiens font l'objet
d'une campagne de désinformation
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Dans cette vidéo publiée
su
parle de pillages et de réfugiés
qui attaquent des camionneurs
et volent leurs véhicules.
Ici, cet homme reproche
des Ukrainiens qui roulent
en voitures luxueuses, aueueueue
la Moldavie est l'un des pays
les plus pauvres d'Europe.
d'exagération, selon la
journaliste Malalalalalache.
- Si elle reconnaît que le poids
économique estrnrnrnrnrnrnrnrnre
que l'immense majorité
des réfugiés qui restent
en Moldavie sont hébergés
par de D D D D D D D D D D D D ,
cette vérificatrice de faits
constate une augmentation
dans la publication de fausses
Dans cette ancienne république
soviétique où se trouve toujo
un territoire autoproclamé
appuyé par la Russie,
un problème loin d'être inédit.
- Pendant 30 ans de l'existence
toujours confrontés à des
fausses informations c
à la propagande, si j'ose dire,
qui est venue surtout de l'Est,
La Moldavie, l'Etat moldave
vraiment par la sécurisation
de son espatatatatatationnel,
malheureusement.
- Cette fois,
les autorités ont décidé d'agir.
À la recommandal'l'l'l'l'l'l'l',
les distributeurs moldaves
ont suspendu temporairement
la retransmission d'émissions
d'informataaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaas
dans ce pays où plus de 10 %
de la population est russophone.
ANETA GONTA, Union intern. de
- - - - - - - - - - - - - - - -t
très partagée en fait, très,
très partagée. Et les gens,
il y a beaucoup de gens
- La guerre en Ukraine,
avec ses conséquences politiques
fragiliser davantage
la Molysysysysysysys qui fait
déjà face à d'énormes défis.
- Mais pour Cristina, la crise
la pauvreté de leur pays,
itititititititité est une ressoe
dont disposent abondamment
les citoyens de la Moldavie.r,r,
Radio-Can